was sind politiker aber auch
kabarettisten oder journalisten ohne ihr
publikum
das war heute im falle der erstgenannten
auf besonders tragische weise zu
beobachten beim politischen
aschermittwoch auch der kreativste
ansatz konnte nicht verbergen
rhetorische raketen zünden ohne den
sprengsatz aus saufen brüllen lachen
verdammt schlecht in den sauren apfel
haben aber alle gewissen denn es ist
wahljahr ohne bier und blasmusik
politischer aschermittwoch 2021 jetzt in
der phoenix runde
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste zunächst hier im studio
liane bett graz ist bei uns zeigen sich
selbst als liberal konservative
publizist in sind auch mitglied in der
cdu wieder zu dick ist journalist und
seine bekannten satirischen
wochenrückblick sind bei fast allen ard
rundfunkanstalten zu hören zugeschaltet
der kabarettist urban priol und der
politikwissenschaftler professor
heinrich oberreuter aus passau
zugeschaltet sie sind auch langjähriges
csu mitglied herr priol in ihrem
berufsstand ist ja mitleid mit politiker
nicht sehr weit verbreitet haben ihnen
die politischen akteure heute trotzdem
etwas leid getan
unter diesen bedingungen eines digitalen
aschermittwoch ja es war nicht schön
also es fehlt natürlich die reaktion es
fehlt das bier geschwängerte publikum
bei olaf scholz war so olaf scholz hat
halt geredet wie olaf scholz redet also
ich glaube er braucht auch ein publikum
bei lindner was sehr herbei wie sich mit
seinem kleinen bierhumpen als er da
stand oben in diesem läuft mit den
großen fenstern die grünen mit wasser
haben sich glaube ich auch keinen
gefallen getan und die csu hat muss mir
sagen technisch am besten hingekriegt
aber inhaltlich war es schon mit dem
brezen und mit dem allem schon etwas zäh
teilweise zum fremdschämen auch dass sie
vorher an die mitglieder noch
aschermittwoch dem packerl mit maß und
bierkrug und bieren und brezen
verschickt haben es gab ja auch mal in
bayern im finale damen vom großen fc
bayern gegen chelsea das ging dann auch
in die rose mal schauen wie es diesmal
aussieht gut jetzt können wir auch
gleich nachprüfen was diese sind
bewertungen die urban barry und gerade
von sich gegeben hat ob es tatsächlich
auch die sich bildlich so umgesetzt
haben sagen dass sowie 26 bilder von den
protagonisten heute also bilder aus
unserer phoenix übertragung ob man da
vielleicht in den gesichtern lesen kann
was es bedeutet unter diesen bedingungen
den politischen aschermittwoch zu
zelebrieren und wir fangen an mit dem
hauptredner der hauptredner markus söder
dem csu ministerpräsidenten in bayern am
historischen ort in passau und
zugeschaltet zu dieser veranstaltung war
seinen parteivorsitzenden freund von der
cdu armin laschet ihr aus düsseldorf
zugeschaltet auch mit bayrischen
accessoires versehen das war eine
premiere dass ein cdu-vorsitzender auf
dem politischen aschermittwoch der csu
austritt olaf scholz war schon
angesprochen hier ist er zu ziehen der
kanzlerkandidat der spd auch am
historischen ort übrigens in vilshofen
im wolferstetter keller dann sehen wir
stefan tutschka vom afd bundesvorstand
auf der kundgebung der afg in greding
das ist ein ort zwischen nürnberg und
ingolstadt
und dann kommt kommen die bündnisgrünen
einer dieser beiden möchte ja kanzlerin
beziehungsweise kanzler werten annalena
baerbock und robert habeck
auf der kundgebung des aschermittwochs
für die bündnisgrünen das sind die
linken in der mitte die zukünftige
parteivorsitzende janine wissler
auch sie war in niederbayern unterwegs
zugeschaltet aus thüringen der wohl
bekannteste grüne in deutschland bodo
ramelow so sieht also die
aschermittwochs kundgebung der linken
aus und schließlich war auch schon
angesprochen von urban priol christian
lendner hoch über münchen schwebend die
aschermittwochs-kundgebung der fdp in
diesem jahr frau cui bono wem nützt es
sagt man immer so schön leben nutzt ein
solcher aschermittwoch naja man kann
sich natürlich de facto nicht dem
entziehen also man muss als partei schon
irgendwas machen
meine persönliche einschätzung wäre da
widerspreche ich ihnen herr priol ich
glaube dass markus söder davor haben
besten gelungen ist übrigens das wage
ich sozusagen hat sich nicht als
eu-mitglied das bin ich nur historisch
also ich spreche als sadisten
aber er hat es einfach geschafft so
ähnlich uns vielleicht hat auch bei
seiner bewerbungsrede hat es geschafft
sehr persönliche statements auch wie
sehr er selber beispielsweise auch die
sorge um die ansteigenden infektions und
todeszahlen in der zweiten welle ihn um
den schlaf gebracht hat also das kam
sehr deutlich zum ausdruck zugleich zu
fahren mit einer sehr sehr
staatsmännischen bdr redete von
verantwortung tätig und lebensschutz
es war ein gewisser weise vielleicht ein
bisschen das fernduell zweier
kanzlerkandidaten
während söder mit dieser zurecht wie
sehr ansprechend etwas bayerischen
gemütlichkeit und da jetzt gegensatz
dann der schmissige hanseat olaf scholz
der über sich hinausgewachsen ist eine
sehr kämpferische rede gehalten hat auch
thematisch über coruna hinaus gehen und
sich als kanzlerkandidat in stellung
brachte auch sagte ich will kanzler
werden und ich glaube für beide waren
das eigentlich heute gute auftritte mit
leichten plus punkten dann aber doch für
hansa oberreuter was wir da gesehen
haben
bei der csu in passau da hat sich also
der ministerpräsidentin ein wie er
gesagt hat fränkisch anmutendes
wohnzimmer gesetzt um live aus passau
seine aschermittwochsrede zu erhalten
das war also der versuch die ganze
bayerische vielfalt dem publikum zu
präsentieren
ja also ich glaube die installierung war
zum teil bayerischer als bayern wirklich
ist wenn man das äußere sich anschaut
fränkisch war schon eigentlich gleich
überhaupt nicht es war also eigentlich
ja ein wohnzimmer als lederhose
und der laptop hat man bei der ist so
glaube ich ganz gut versteckt aber
darauf kam es ja eigentlich nicht so
sehr anders kam darauf an eine ersatz
inszenierung die ähnlich wird wie das
original dem publikum zu präsentieren
und das hatte seine tücken aber es hat
sich immerhin auch den vorteil dass man
zeigen konnte dass man die basis nicht
vergisst und dass man also eine stimme
in der öffentlichkeit denn mitglieder
gegenüber
aber auch der bundesrepublik gegenüber
gerne haben möchte dazu da geht sie
haben sich die übertragung bei phoenix
angesehen nacheinander so wie wir sie
gebracht haben
wie viel ernsthaftigkeit und wieviel
unfreiwillige komik war da eigentlich im
spiel ja unfreiwillige komik ist ja im
heute bewusster komik hat es noch nie
gegeben beim politischen aschermittwoch
das ist immer daneben gegangen
wenn die leute da versucht haben humorig
zu sein das war in aller regel karla
fest übelster sorte ist die colour
werden auch recycelt jedes jahr
es kommt immer dasselbe übrigens söder
heute auch wieder an von 2020 recycelt
dass er gerne einen baum umarmt aber
nicht die grünen heute war dass er gerne
einen baum am abend aber nicht herrn
hofreiter das ist schon traurig ich habe
vor jahren schon gesagt man sollte den
politischen aschermittwoch abschaffen
ich denke heute unter corona bedingungen
war das die selbstabschaffung es wurden
reden gehalten
über die kann man sagen ob sie gute
reden waren oder schlechte reden waren
ich stimme ihnen zu frau bednarz scholz
hat eine sehr engagierte rede gehalten
also ich kenne ihn noch ganz anders
gut dann muss man nicht von vor 100
jahren reden also derjenige slow ziel wo
er in dieser rede gehalten sind weil sie
nicht als generalsekretär
war und man ihn scholzomat ein weil er
immer diese diese gestanzten dinge von
sich ab liest also dagegen war das heute
schon eine tolle angelegenheit aber
ansonsten ich überlege mir mal für wen
das eigentlich ist dieser politische
aschermittwoch war von der tradition her
eine gaudi veranstaltung auch wenn immer
alle gesagt haben das ist keine
natürlich war sie immer eine für das
publikum für die basis in vilshofen
ursprünglich und dann in passau und es
war von übel dass sich alle anderen
möglichen parteien daran gehen da haben
wir erstmal der cdu/csu weiter
überlassen sollen eine gaudi kann man
nach hin man kann es auch lassen
brüll orgien sauforgien alles wunderbar
franz josef strauß der angeblichen guter
redner war ja zum teufel er hat drei
stunden lang ein volkswirtschaftliches
seminar abgehalten und zwischendurch
immer mal paar gehässigkeiten über den
politischen gegner losgelassen das ist
politischer aschermittwoch das heute war
keiner und ich hoffe es werden alle
seien gut vielleicht war die langjährige
oder jahrzehntelange sollte fuchs der
bei brioni ja das habe ich ja auch
markus söder erkannt heute morgen gesagt
hat ja früher patzer halbe stunde dauert
bis man mit dem defiliermarsch endlich
einmarschiert war
heute geht es wesentlich schneller aber
viel mehr muss ich sagen außer wie
gesagt gebe ich recht eine gelungene
inszenierung aber vom inhalt her bei
söder eher weniger aber das kennt man
bei ihm eigentlich schon seit beginn der
pandemie dass die inszenierung oftmals
doch wichtiger ist als der inhalt
das gilt für viele andere
veranstaltungen wahrscheinlich auch wir
reden über inszenierung und inhalte in
dieser sendung
das kann jetzt schon so ein bisschen
durch diese der aschermittwoch ich sag
es mal nicht nur als gaudi sondern
gelegentlich auch als bierernst
vielleicht auch mit betonung auf bier
ist eine solche veranstaltung auch jetzt
unter diesen bedingungen deplatziert in
corona zeiten
na ja man hat es ja schon versucht so zu
gestalten auch durch diese reden ja
überwiegend sehr ernsthaft waren oder
ganz überwiegend zur waise ernsthaft mit
wenigen kleinen spitzen und humor ich
denke das freute auch dazu dienen
ein bisschen normalität zu wahren und
den leuten das gefühl zu geben das ist
jetzt vielleicht ein besonderer
aschermittwoch aber das ist jetzt nicht
das ende einer liebgewonnenen tradition
die ja nun wirklich in bayern wichtig
ist also ich habe in meiner studienzeit
in passau das oft selber live erlebt
also das ist schon teil einfach der
bayerischen csu kultur das interessante
fand ich wenn man mal genauer hingehört
hat was herr söder dann doch in kleinen
nebensätzen im bunde abgelassen hat
unter stechen für mich zwei punkte
heraus
zum einen hat ja ich glaube sogar
zweimal gegen die freien wähler also
immer in seinen koalitionspartner
geschossen in münchen und als er über
koalitionsoption auf bundesebene sprach
dafür bringen sich nämlich jetzt die
freien wähler ins spiel und da sagte er
na ja also eine koalition in bayern mit
denen reicht das ist schon ein bisschen
erstaunlich dass so deutlich zu sagen
und das zweite war und das habe ich
persönlich verstanden als kleine spitze
gegen laschet
er sagte nämlich dass sozusagen die
bisherigen unions stimmen das sind
merkel stimmen
und wer jetzt meint geben merkel
wahlkampf machen zu müssen sind gemäss
tue sich keinen gefallen
und mein eindruck war dass bei aller
sozusagen fast schon über betonten
harmonie mit mit unserem kurzen auftritt
heute fand ich das erstaunlich besonders
damit dass sich das lasse sich an gerade
in den letzten tagen von merkel kurs
dass die schutzmaßnahmen angeht versucht
hat mal wieder zu distanzieren
ich kann ihnen aushilfen mit dem zitat
merkel stimme er mit merkel politik da
ist das eine frage gestellt bevor später
zu den inhalten von heute kommt ist denn
nach diesen digitalen aschermittwoch
unter der voraussetzung wir kriegen
corona in den griff nächstes jahr
einfach wieder so an diese nahtlos an
diese tradition seit 1919 anzuknüpfen
oder hat es tatsächlich einen bruch
gegeben jetzt eine zäsur dieser
veranstaltung
also ich erlaubt man trotzdem als
drittes element zu sehen von frank
peters hinzuzufügen dass die aussage
dass die fdp der liebste
koalitionspartner wäre da vielleicht
verlässlichste
natürlich auch eine politische botschaft
war das andere thema das die welt
interessiert sei neben der
aschermittwoch in eine neue phase
eingetreten ist das ist die frage ist
eher noch zeitgemäß ich glaube diese
frage wird man seit 20 jahren jedes jahr
vorgelegt und ich meine dass das was man
als folkloristisches oder auch
humoristisches und ja auch die die
wähler und die basis auf eine eher
emotionalen grundlage ansprechende
programmatik dieses ereignisses
ansprechen darf dass das ein typus
eigener art ist übrigens nicht schon
seit 1911
da war es der viehmarkt diese form ist
eigentlich eine nachkriegs form geworden
und man hat bei franz josef strauß schon
gesehen wie problematisch das ist es ja
schon jemand gesagt das war ein
volkswirtschaftliches seminare aber er
hat in aller regelmäßigkeit nach 15
minuten gesehen dass das publikum
schläft und dann hat er eine rakete
losgelöst und dann ist die
emotionalisierung eingetreten und ich
glaube dass wir mit unseren rationalen
argumenten diesen aschermittwoch nicht
umbringen werden da wird wechselt ja
wieder stattfinden und ich frag mich
wenn er so außerhalb der zeit ist also
mein element ist es auch nicht wenn also
außerhalb der zweite ist warum kopieren
alle andere parteien dieses ereignis und
maschinen in bayern auf um der csu
sozusagen das monopol einer solchen
eines solchen emotionalen ereignis
nichts zu gewähren
also jeder denkt er hat was davon und
oberreuter gelingt es den realien dahin
in der äußeren in der äußeren
erscheinungsform in dem jeder eine eine
veranstaltung macht ja aber was die
resonanz betrifft eigentlich wenn ich
das überblicke relativ nein das
interessante heute war ja eigentlich
dann doch noch sehr emotionaler auftritt
von einer chance der zum ersten mal der
spd eigentlich in na ja in eine leichte
konkurrenz zur csu überlegenheit
gebracht hat aber es ist ein ereignis
das in der tat so csu am meisten nützt
und alle anderen schauen dass ich nicht
ins abseits gerät und die schauen dass
oder meinen das bier und brezn aus ja
ich finde auch mal sollte es eigentlich
den politischen aschermittwoch sollte
man der csu als monopol überlassen als
gesamt bayerische folklore bis es sich
dann irgendwann totläuft sowie
irgendwann nach dem 0 6 supergewinn der
fc bayern irgendwann ist die leute
hatten immer interessiert also ich denke
auch die csu sollte so weiter machen das
ist gut das ist wunderbar
prima bis ich die leute irgendwann
denken ja schon wieder ich sag gut jetzt
es läuft sie es läuft sich ja mal droht
wird die partei mit ihren pappkameraden
aufmarschiert was jetzt vielleicht auch
den einen oder anderen technischen
effekt haben könnte denn nicht alle hier
als hasen anwesen sind sind auch in der
realität keine pappkameraden also sollte
man jetzt also sehr interessante
psychologische studien veranstalter
jetzt so gerne an kommt ein ganz nicht
wo er war seltsamerweise bei den
pappkameraden nicht sichtbar am anfang
fand ich auch interessant
ich wollte nur kurz noch ergänzen ich
würde es nicht zu sehr als folklore
abtun und zwar deshalb weil das geld um
uns für die spd genauso beide
volksparteien müssen schon aufpassen und
dass sie den kontakt zu den
wählerschichten nicht verlieren die sich
vielleicht durchaus kulturell in zeiten
der globalisierung abgehängt werden wir
haben wir nicht umsonst seit jahren
jetzt auch diese ganze heimat debatte
und
das gilt auch für die cdu die wirklich
vielfach auch durchaus und den ganzen
ganzen kreis und ortsverbände durchaus
auch kleinbürgerlich geprägt ist und
diese brauchtumspflege ist den leuten
schon auch wichtig und sozusagen
versuchen damit den leuten auch ein
angebot zu machen auch wenn das
vielleicht ist auf uns ein bisschen
befremdlich wirkt muss nicht unbedingt
falsch seien auch vor dem hintergrund
dass man aufpassen muss dass ebensolche
solche wieder nichts half der abwandern
und das gefühl haben das ist jetzt
plötzlich die neue partei auch für die
kleinen leute und das gilt besonders für
die csu das eine richtige weg das ist ja
auch die frage wie politik verkauft wird
wenn teile des politischen
aschermittwoch urban priol realsatire
sind stellt sich ja gleich die frage hat
es satire denn überhaupt er in kona
zeiten leichter oder schwerer also
generell haben wir seit ein paar jahren
glaube ich das problem dass es schwer
fällt die von den politikern dargebotene
satire noch zu überbieten also das ist
schon viel viel arbeit und es war auch
heute ersichtlich also den gastauftritt
von armin laschet entschuldigung mal
also wie willst du dann noch drüber
gehen das kannst du nicht mehr schaffen
dass er wirklich her geht und dann
zitiert er schiller und dann kommt er
mit freude schöner götterfunken und wir
betreten freudetrunken nämlich ein
heiligtum um sich an die csu so was von
anzuwachsen es war ja schon ähnlich
peinlich als er bei der ersten koalition
beim koalitionsgipfel wo er als neuer
cdu vorsitzender kam heinrich heine
bände verteilt hat er hat glaube ich
nicht gewusst wirklich was eine so alles
geschrieben hat also aber er kam als
gast oder in der nacht keine kam auf
diesen job gebracht
zumba ist wahrscheinlich nur ein land
ist einer von mir
er kommt aus düsseldorf das ist einer
von mir dann bringe ich da eben mal mit
peter zu tagen voller komik ist immer
unfreiwillig das heißt also politiker es
gibt ja jetzt das heiligtum von dem
urban priol steht war ja das wohnzimmer
von markus söder das war sicherlich
vielleicht auch etwas unbeabsichtigt
aber ist es wirklich so dass man sich
dann nicht inszeniert sondern das
einfach glaubt man ist auf einer ernst
politischen veranstaltung und dann
rutscht eine unfreiwillige komik so aus
oder wird das vielleicht inzwischen auch
von politikern ganz gezielt eingesetzt
ja da bin ich nicht so ganz sicher also
die inszenierung zunächst mal von der
csu war eigentlich ziemlich gut wenn man
sich anschaut was die für eine tolle
wand hatten da wo ziemlich viele leute
zugeschaltet waren die davor vor ihren
laptops oder sonstwie saßen und auch
applaudierten also das haben sie prima
gemacht aber dann war halt das zentrum
des des ganzen die ihre die rede von
söder in einem er hat ja vorher gesagt
ja so könnte es in meinem wohnzimmer
auch aussehen das ist natürlich relativ
albern alle auf der anderen seite was
hätten sie machen sollen sowie lindner
das war nun wirklich schauerlich wie der
da vor einer glaswand einem fenster
steht das herausschaut auf hochhäuser in
münchen das war so steife leinen das
geht schon immer schlimmer also ich
denke schon dass söder schlau genug ist
auch mit gekriegt zu haben na ja das ist
schon so ein bisschen komisch hier aber
da kommen wir jetzt heute mal durch
während wenn ich darf auch noch priol
aufzunehmen was laschet anbetrifft also
noch peinlicher kann man eigentlich
nicht auftreten
und ich habe den großen verdacht dass
laschet der hat sich ja für den
humoristen kommt aus aachen die hatten
sich glaube ich alle fristen dass
laschet wirklich gedacht hat ach ich
mache jetzt mal sowas humoristische und
sage ich trete ein in das himmelreich in
den olymp ich darf als erster beim beim
politischen aschermittwoch der csu
teilnehmen ist miss lied ich behalt er
kann es nicht er ist nur albern und ist
nur peinlich für mich nicht ich bin
nicht in der cdu aber buch ich weiß
nicht wie es ausgegangen ist ja ich
hab's auch peinlich also dann plötzlich
beethoven zu zitieren die ode an die
freude das war nun wirklich also
peinlichst pathos geraten darf ich auch
gezockt und er hat natürlich im boden
versucht sich als die erwähnten ja zu
recht als rheinische frohnatur
da einzubringen dass am aschermittwoch
vielleicht auch nicht ganz passend und
er hat im grunde so diesen sehr
speziellen
der macher mittwochs humor nicht
wirklich verstanden als wird auch
anbiedernd und wenn man weiß dass beide
ja schon konkurrenten sind auch so diese
wechselseitige beschwörung der großen
einheit der partei oder auch der
einigkeit wie gesagt aber mit dieser
deutlichen spitze von soda andererseits
naja ein bisschen dick aufgetragen das
fand ich auch gut
sie haben glaube ich vorhin auch gesagt
ich würde sagen dieser dieser wie soll
ich mal sagen krude aschermittwochs
humor war doch eigentlich heute
nirgendwo existent der witz war doch
dass diese art unserer urteil der oder
vorurteile über dieses ereignis das wir
mit uns herumtragen dass die heute eben
nicht inszeniert worden sind ich meine
dass jeder hat doch eine in der tat eher
staatsmännisch ist falsch aber eine
ernsthafte rede gehalten er hat ja doch
ein paar ganz kleine humoristische neben
äußerung getan mit hofreiter und den
baum und den grünen
aber ansonsten war das ja doch eine eine
in die indy wie soll ich mal sagen in
die pandemie seele
der nation hineingeredet ernsthaft
bestandsaufnahme mit verteidigung der
politischen strategie die sich
durchgesetzt hat und auch mit
perspektiven wie es denn weitergehen
könnte unter der voraussetzung dass man
das ding beherrscht also so ganz ganz
unernst der abklatsch
den habe ich eigentlich dort nicht
entdeckt sondern ganz im gegenteil die
frage ist noch ob zudem wie wir dieses
instrument dieses verhaltensmuster und
kommunikationsmuster aufpassen wie wir
es immer interpretieren ob das was heute
gelaufen ist das überhaupt passt
und da würde ich sagen also als einen
ganz erheblichen bruch gegeben
es war der versuch also zu reagieren
aber nicht nur bei der csu übrigens
sondern bei den meisten anderen auch zu
reagieren auf die emotionale und
rationale herausforderung der
bevölkerung der politik gegenüber jahr
einen virus dass der mensch nicht
beherrschen kann und das sozusagen also
seine eigenen gesetzlichkeiten der
menschlichkeit der menschheit unter
politik aufzwingt und man hat
schwierigkeiten dem zu begegnen
also das war der hintergrund und dem
hintergrund ist mir relativ glaube ich
durchaus gerecht geworden und so eine
reine folklore war das nicht und ist es
eigentlich auch sowieso weil ich
missverstanden worden nie gewesen denn
es war immer auch der versuch bei diesem
ereignis die eigene basis zu einer
resonanz zu bringen auch zu testen wie
weit man gehen kann und es hat schon
inszenierung gegeben in der die partie
die anwesenden parteimitglieder und
sympathisanten durchaus mal in berufe
ausgebrochen ist oder auch dem
parteivorsitzenden klar gemacht haben
dass ich eine bestimmte richtung nicht
gehen wollen also das ist schon ganz
wichtig und das ja auch vorhin schon
gesagt worden
wir brauchen instrumente der
rückkoppelung zwischen führung basis
regierung und bevölkerung da ist es ein
instrument war wenn auch ein besonderes
aber dieses instrument hatte diesmal
seine besondere eigenart und der
eigenart glaube ich
ist es über weite strecken gerecht
geworden und laschet ist natürlich
sicher kein kommunikation chemie und was
wir da gesehen haben heute war ja
eigentlich eine inszenierung um
konflikte zu vermeiden und zumindest als
auch bis vor mitte märz keinen kampf um
die kanzlerkandidatur zu inszenieren
sonst hätte das ganze ja auch gar nicht
stattgefunden also wie camel denn die
csu auf die idee zu ihrem hochamt den
vorsitzenden der cdu einzuladen und wie
kempter cdu vorsitzende auf die idee
nach bayern zu reisen wenn es denn
körperlich möglich gewesen wäre
also das hat alles seine perspektive auf
das september dieses jahres und das
sollte man glaube ich mit berücksichtigt
ich darf ich ganz kurz sagen ich bedanke
mich erstmal bei professor uwe reuter
darf ich leider ganz kurzer brief
bedanke mich erstmal einen opera dass
sie mir die anmoderation abgenommen
haben für einen videoausschnitt von
markus söder den wir ihnen nämlich jetzt
erst mal zeigen wollen da geht es
nämlich nachdenklichkeit und die
ernsthaftigkeit sie haben davon die am
anfang auch schon gesprochen
wir schauen uns mal einen kurzen rede
ausschnitt aus dem wohnzimmer von markus
sudan
für mich sind todesfälle und jeder
einzelne ein stich ins herz
es ist keine floskel jedes mal ein stich
ins herz ich erlebt dann oft wie manch
einer sagt ich bin ein opfer der
pandemie oder meine zielkugel weil ich
dies oder jenes nicht darf die wahren
opfer der pandemie sind 65.000 menschen
die tot sind
die haben keine öffnungs perspektive
markus söder jetzt ist die frage auch
nach dem was professor oberreuter gerade
gesagt hat dass es eben nicht eine gaudi
veranstaltung sondern sie soll ja auch
ernsthaftigkeit transportieren unter den
bedingungen von krone ist das besonders
wichtig hätte markus söder in einer
vollbesetzten dreiländerhalle in passau
einen solchen satz gesagt ich glaube an
der jetzigen situation schon an und ich
hatte das der eingangs bewusst auch
betont dass ich habe ja die rede genau
so verstanden als sehr staatsmännisch
sehr besonnen ging es doch nur zu sagen
dass der auftritt von laschet mit diesem
rheinischen humor nicht wirklich dazu
passte ich denke ja denn er tritt ja
schon dass die ganze zeit über sehr
besonnen auf es war auch ganz
interessantesten der anmoderation
wiederum der generalsekretär blume sagte
er
aber letzten monaten doch einen sünder
erlebte er sehr nachdenklich ist sehr
abwägend und er hat dann ja auch im
weiteren verlauf der rede geschildert
dass es eben immer darauf ankommt ja
abzuwägen dass man nicht irgendwelche
daten fiktiv setzen kann an denen man
jetzt wieder öffnet er hat zu
nachhaltigem handeln angemahnt und eben
explizit mehrfach auch gesagt wo zu
vorschnell eröffnungen führen können er
nannte die beispiele von irland und
portugal auch österreich tirol wo man
eben zu schnell agiert hat dachte man
habe das virus im griff er sprach die
mutationen an konnte dann ganz aktuell
die neuen erschreckenden zahlen von
herrn spahn auch zitieren wonach ihr 22
prozent der neuinfektionen auf gut
handeln zurückzuführen sind vor zwei
wochen waren es noch 6 prozent
und diese haltung kriegt so der ja schon
lange er sprach dann auch davon dass er
doch sehr angefeindet werde von
rechtsradikalen und
verschwörungstheoretikern der sei
regelrecht zielscheibe geworden aber das
eben eine partei wie die dass ich auch
eine sehr wichtigen satz sind eine
partei wie die csu kann es sich nicht
leisten eine partei der irrtümer zu sein
sie müsse eine partei sein die führt und
dieser satz eben speziell zu den toten
oder diese passage finde ich hat
eigentlich das was ihn antreibt aus
meiner sicht aus werden sehr ehrliche
art wie er das gesagt hat auch die mimik
doch sehr zum ausdruck das heißt form
und inhalt passen da eigentlich gar
nicht zusammen
ich frage mich warum man dazu diese
institution politischen aschermittwoch
braucht was herr söder gesagt hat na ja
nicht so ganz kurzen rede was alle
anderen gesagt haben haben sie in den
vergangenen wochen in regelmäßigen
abständen sehr kurzen abständen in ihren
pressekonferenzen gesagt in ihren reden
vor den verschiedenen landesparlamenten
das haben wir alles schon nicht nur wir
journalisten die damit vollgestopft sind
bis oben hin sondern auch das publikum
hat das alles schon gehört warum brauche
ich also sowas
naja es so dass perspektive kann ich mir
das vorstellen ich bekomme jetzt ich
weiß nicht wie lange es war zwei stunden
oder so oder an als habe ich bekomme
jetzt zwei stunden in phoenix um das
ganze noch mal so richtig aus zu
bereiten
und eine gute figur zu machen das gönne
ich ihm aber wozu brauche ich den
politischen aschermittwoch dann kann man
lieber absagen und politik so
weitermachen wie bisher wenn man das für
richtig
priol dann kann man ja den politischen
aschermittwoch könnte man auch im
kanzleramt abhalten
also den politischen aschermittwoch was
würden wir ja ohnehin täglich der ist ja
immer da ist ja immer es ständig pathos
kann der franke das hat man wieder
gesehen immer wenn pathos einstellen
brief vorlesen von einem schulmädchen
das gesagt hat toll wie ihr uns kümmert
und was man alles machen für euch und
noch wenig pathos er ist ja im
morgenmagazin es im mittagsmagazin ist
in allen talkshows
er ist überall also ich warte nur noch
darauf dass er irgendwann in der sendung
mit der maus einer auftaucht und am ende
wird gesagt das war fraglich
aber dafür braucht es wirklich den
politischen also mittwoch mittlerweile
nicht mehr er ist so oft da und alle
leute sagen dann natürlich selbst und
weise der sünde
der ist so oft im fernsehen das ist der
muss gut sein den wählern mehr
es gibt nur noch einen der öfter ist und
das ist professor karl lauterbach von
der spd nur bei dem schlägt gerade in
die andere richtung um komischerweise
gut für alle nicht franken was meint
pathos des bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten und jetzt eigentlich
gegenstück sowohl in der inszenierung
wie auch im inhalt gibt es auch schon
kurz angesprochen christian lindner hoch
über münchen schwebend und er hat sich
inhaltlich die den kontrapunkt zu markus
söder gesetzt manche bemerkung aus dem
mund von ministerpräsidenten hört sich
nicht an nach pandemie bekämpfung
sondern nach stubenarrest wenn man den
menschen verhängen muss und daraus meine
damen und herren muss sich unser land
nach einem jahr der pandemie endlich
befreien
die letzten worte er hat er noch
abgelesen verbittert
diese äußerungen der kontrapunkt zu
sagen hier werden freiheitsrechte
eingeschränkt im moment haben wir ja
offenbar so einen stimmungsumschwung es
gibt jetzt umfrage die sagen dass die
mehrheit der bevölkerung eigentlich
nicht mehr zufrieden ist mit der korona
politik der bundesregierung bzw
der länderregierungschefs hat da einer
schon witterung aufgenommen
ja und maßlos überzogen als ich das
gehört habe hat dachte ich wie geht
diese rede jetzt bloß weiter
gott sei dank hatte sich dann aber im
weiteren verlauf gemäßigt auch klar von
stimmen wie jetzt aus der afg abgesetzt
die die sozusagen in foto ja auch diese
schutzmaßnahmen ganz gerne in frage
stellen man muss natürlich sagen die fdp
hat als klassische freiheits problem
partei moment ein problem sie muss sich
für für freiheit in gewisser weise
einsetzen auf der anderen seite gibt es
ein tödliches virus und hiervon
stuhlmacher ist zu streichen ist
schlichtweg deplatziert denn es ist ein
virus das mutiert ist breitet sich aus
also auf freiheiten zu kochen bei einer
situation die nicht kontrollierbar ist
und wo es darum geht das leben der
bevölkerung letztlich zu schützen ist in
dieser pauschalität falsch dass man
natürlich diskutieren sollte wann sind
eröffnungen perspektivisch möglich dass
man stufen pläne entwickeln soll dass
das bisher zu wenig passiert oder
defizitär ist gar keine frage
aber ich finde hat am anfang überzogen
damit mit diesem ausdruck denn es geht
ja nicht darum dass man leute agusta
irgendwie einsperren möchte er hat aber
im weiteren verlauf der rede etwas
interessantes oder zwei wichtige punkte
gesagt die beide auch nicht neu sind
aber trotzdem wichtig zu betonen
zum einen nannte er die schnelltests
game changer dass sie also wirklich
schnell jetzt auch eingeführt werden
kostenlos das ist dass es am besten eine
app gibt dann lässt man sich testen und
kann dann praktisch eine gewisse anzahl
von stunden hat man ein zertifikat und
kann sich daneben bekommt immer freier
dann ein neues möglicherweise wenn die
ressorts wieder öffnen
und der zweite punkt waren den abhang
finde ich auch nicht unterschätzen und
da macht die regierung auch fehler
er sagte dass mehr debatten im parlament
auch einen versenden effekt hätten haben
können oder perspektivisch haben können
weil dann zumindest alternativkonzepte
im parlament diskutiert werden und dann
das fand ich einen schönen spruch sagte
er das würde nämlich die minderheit
selbst wenn sie dann unterliegt weil die
regierung anders handelt aber doch mit
der regierung sind wir dann
mehr versöhnen wenn man das gefühl hat
es wird im plenum debattiert und das
hatte ich nur sehr gute aussage sonst
ganz kurz noch bei dem begriff
stubenarrest bleiben der zukünftige
christian lindner ist der zukünftige
lieblings koalitionspartner von armin
laschet der ja vor einigen tagen in
einem interview der bild zeitung gesagt
die politik muss aufpassen dass sie die
bevölkerung nicht wie unmündige kinder
behandelt das geht ja so ein bisschen in
richtung stubenarrest ist das der neue
ton mit dem jetzt versucht wird eben die
korona politik der kanzlerin zu
konterkarieren
ja da bin ich nicht so ganz sicher bei
laschet er sagt heute mal so und morgen
mal so und morgen wir werden ein anderes
zitat von ihm hören und er wird uns
erklären warum die einander nicht
widersprechen
da würde ich mich nicht darauf verlassen
dass mit dem stubenarrest frau bednarz
ja natürlich ist das überzogen lindner
ist einer der auf keine pointe
verzichten will
das ist doch klar aber das war
wenigstens das letzte zipfelchen von
politischen aschermittwoch sowie wm-ball
gekannt haben vor 40 jahren oder so also
das würde ich ihm durchgehen lassen
begriff ist einer kürzlichen dann gilt
das was ich gesagt habe aus § 1 dann
verzichten auf diesen politischen
aschermittwoch unter diesen bedingungen
dann gar keine reden denn alles andere
was geredet wurde nochmal das ist die
bad wickel maschine das haben wir alles
alles alles hundertmal dann bitte herr
priol und danach eroberte und events
noch wir wenn es noch die am ende auch
noch 100 mal hören und das andere dass
laschet gesagt hat ja man muss aufpassen
dass man mit uns den folgen mündigen
bürger dem souveränen nicht so umgeht
als werden wir kleine verzogene kinder
ich meine was wir in den letzten monaten
gehört haben wir wurden wer wirklich so
ein bisschen behandelt wie die deppen
ist die gar nicht selbst entscheiden
können aber die kanzlerin als staats
gouvernante spricht schon seit über 15
jahren so zu uns es wundert mich dass es
bislang noch niemandem aufgefallen ist
naja also wenn drin wenn ich eine kurze
zwischenbilanz ziehen das budget
betrifft dann ist das was ich gehört
habe ein flammendes plädoyer für die
kanzlerschaft für die kanzlerkandidatur
von hans söllner gewesen bisher den
laschet nimmt offenbar in diesem kreis
so gut wie niemand angst
zumindest was seine kommunikations und
für talente betrifft vielleicht ist gar
nicht so schlimm wie es hier so
dargestellt wird
aber er hat eben signalisiert hat
gezeigt warum wir die probleme hat die
hat aber auf der anderen seite würde ich
doch schon dafür plädieren dass man die
herausforderung vor der wir stehen ich
habe das am anfang schon mal versucht zu
skizzieren
dass wir die ernst nehmen wir haben
keine erfahrung mit einer pandemie die
tödlich ist die tödlich ist weit über
die grenzen deutschlands hinaus die
nicht nur 65.000 menschen verschluckt
hat sondern in amerika allein eine halbe
million und weltweit will ich jetzt also
die die zählung nicht weitertreiben und
wir haben keine verlässliche methode mit
diesen dingen umzugehen solange wir
keinen impfschutz haben sind wir in der
notwendigkeit mit solchen schutz mit
katastrophenschutz mit in der verfassung
grund gelegten ausnahmeerscheinungen und
ausnahme kompetenzen damit umzugehen
dass die souveränität der menschen
gewisse grenzen hat damit umzugehen das
haben wir im sommer gesehen und die
zweite welle hat durchaus etwas damit zu
tun dass das was an einschränkenden
vorgaben empfohlen worden ist nicht in
ausreichendem umfang umgesetzt worden
ist also für mich gehört zur politischen
führung durchaus in einen notstand auch
mit den entsprechenden maßnahmen zu
agieren zumal diese maßnahmen alle unter
rechtlicher kontrolle stehen und
letztendlich immer auch politisch
legitimiert sind also so leicht dass man
das so wegschwemmen kann und auch mit
mit geradezu kabarettistischen
formulierungen kam als ich das nicht
machen und der begriff stubenarrest ist
absolut
unangemessen und dann müsste man auch
die sp die fdp in der grundeinstellung
mal befragen und manche anderen auch sie
immer nur sagen lockern lockern lockern
locken lockern
welche konsequenzen das nach sich zieht
mit einer dritten welle und ähnlichen
erscheinungen
darüber sollten verantwortlich handelnde
politiker auch mal nachdenken und auch
am aschermittwoch das gehört dazu und
ich finde wenn am aschermittwoch und
politiker malen die chance hat eine
stunde lang zusammenhängend die
herausforderung und potenzielle
möglichkeiten darzustellen ist das
durchaus auch ein angebot für das
publikum
die medien schnäppchen die wir da immer
haben mit zwei minuten 30 die sind
komplexität der gesamten herausforderung
durchaus nicht angemessen also lassen
wir mal die kühe oder die die herde oder
wen auch immer beim dorf- und sind wir
mal froh und dankbar dass selber auch
noch leute gibt die ernsthaft mit der
sache sich auseinandersetzen und die
eben wissen dass die freiheit des
individuums beschränkt ist beide
freiheit endet an der nasenspitze meines
gegenübers und es hat niemals das recht
einen anderen mit seinem virus zu
infizieren und darauf muss die politik
antworten geben und so ist es ja auch in
gewisser weise und da ich meine
sympathie mehr bei denen die die
ernsthafte rolle spielen aus den bei
denen die so tun als ob er das leicht
und locker weg spielen könnte jetzt hat
ja dazu da gefahren gesagt stubenarrest
zwar einer der letzten spieltagen
früherer aschermittwochsveranstaltungen
wo man dann gerne mal übertrieben hat
was wir jetzt von von von
christian lindner da gesehen haben diese
diese auseinandersetzung wie wir das
eigentlich jetzt weiterentwickeln wenn
wir jetzt der politische aschermittwoch
hat keine unterbrechung gegeben das war
eben keine politische gaudi
veranstaltung sondern es ist politisch
einfach geht weiter in diesem wahljahr
was hat dieser aschermittwoch was zeigt
er das ist eigentlich der beginn des
wahlkampfs der inoffizielle weil
wahlkampf ist für dieses jahr
naja also er zeigt auf jeden fall
sondern dieses fernduell scholz versus
söder auf denen das glaube ich zumindest
hinauslaufen wird da kann ich mich
meinem vorredner nur anschließen
aber er zeigt eben auch dass das ist der
kern konflikt den es jetzt geben wird
zwischen schutz auch da stimme ich an
oberreiter vollkommen zu gerade auch aus
mal christlich konservativen perspektive
herr söder betonte wie gesagt das wort
lebensschutz herr blume übrigens auch
und dann eben diesen diesen menschen die
freiheit rufen und nicht sehen dass es
eben nicht darum geht leuten jetzt
freiheiten zu nehmen weil man spaß und
freude daran hätte es kann ja auch die
immer gleichen begriffe bevormundung und
das finde ich auch vom vokabular ist das
schlichtweg in dieser lage unangemessen
das ist eben auch richtig dass aufgrund
des landes jetzt auch mal fehlverhaltens
und der leichtsinnigkeit gewisser
gruppen gerade übrigens auch der jungen
heute im sommer das waren hamburgs oder
wurden ja irgendwann dann auch bestimmte
straßenzüge musste man dann irgendwann
masken tragen weil er auch wieder so
viel gefeiert wurde
oder man hat dann außen außengastronomie
hat alkohol ausgeschenkt hat sein
mandant auch trauben von leuten und das
war tatsächlich so dass vor diesem
echten ausbruch der zweiten welle sich
das virus gerade in diesem
bevölkerungsgruppen sehr verbreitet hat
und so hart das klingen mag manchmal
muss man eben den menschen vor sich
selbst schützen damit er andere nicht
ansteckt und last but not least dann
heißt es ja oft man müsste die
wohlhabenden gruppen schützen das so sei
die priorität sicherlich auch meine
mutter ist selber im pflegeheim gott sei
dank jetzt geimpft aber es sind nicht
nur die wohl haben gruppen ich habe in
meinem persönlichen freundeskreis leute
meines alters die hatten milde verläufe
aber auch jemand der war im krankenhaus
und bei all denen sind jetzt auch noch
wochen später wirklich heftige
folgebeschwerden
wenn man gar nicht dass als folge
beschwerden haben über einbringen hat
schon mehrfach angesprochen olaf scholz
auftritt in vilshofen da hatte er unter
anderem gesagt ich will bundeskanzler
werden muss er sagen denn er ist
kanzlerkandidat die spd in diesem ganzen
kontext wie ist die hat ja liegt immer
noch hinter den grünen in den umfragen
entweder bleibt sie juniorpartner in
einer großen koalition oder sie wird
juniorpartner unter einem bündnis grünen
kanzler eine kanzlerin wie ist die
situation die innenpolitische situation
der spd zu beginn dieses wahljahres aber
nur nach umfragen geht ist sie natürlich
desolat und scholl zu designen tun
tapfer so als gäbe ist diese umfragen
nicht und sagen aber wir haben unsere
stärken weisen tatsächlich auch für
dinge hin die sie in der großen
koalition durchgesetzt haben die
durchgesetzt wurden weil sie da in
dieser koalition waren und stolz sagt
immer wieder es geht um führung und wir
können führung
ja da muss mal gucken was die wähler
dazu sagen ich bin immer ein bisschen
überrascht mit welcher verve scholz das
vorträgt dass er nicht nur kanzler
werden will sondern auch wird klar muss
er sagen ob das jemals noch greift das
die wähler auf diese linie einschwenken
ja die spd hat da eine gescheite politik
gemacht also wählen was er jetzt mal zu
ein bisschen mehr als 15 prozent das ist
die große frage und vielleicht kommt die
fdp in klammern söder hat die fdp heute
auf eine art und weise umarmt die mich
sehr gewundert hat sie sprachen ja
laschet fdp an süder war derjenige der
gesagt hat das ist unser natürlicher
koalitionspartner aber vielleicht kommt
auch bei einer kombination spd mit
grünen die fdp wieder rein um an die
macht zu kommen also die zeiten der
lindner aus koalitionsverhandlungen
weggelaufen ist die sind vorbei um an
die macht zu kommen tut lindner
sicherlich einiges wobei priol war das
nicht blaupause für die wahlkampfführung
von olaf scholz
ich weiß nicht also soll dagegen was man
neuen baum gefunden den er umarmen kann
den gelben fdp baum
das ist richtig leider ist nicht mehr
der aktive baum so in der fdp wie man
sich wünschen würde aber bei der spd so
habe ich mir ja gut da muss man den
großen genossen steinmeier fragen warum
er die spd überhaupt noch mal in diese
letzte hoffentlich finale große
koalition hineingezwungen hat was ihr
sicherlich nicht gut bekommen ist und ob
es besser wird wenn es denn so weit
kommen könnte dass sie in welcher form
auch immer
die regierungspartei nein ich will keine
utopien an die wand malen die sowieso
nicht stattfinden wenn ich denke mal
scholz hat eine rede gehalten die
erhaltene scholz rede war
ob es der spd was bringt wird die zeit
zeigen weil die zeit der vergangenen
jahre hat gezeigt dass die spd in dem
was sie bewegt und gemacht hat nicht
vorkam und die union ist immer schön an
ihre wehr geheftet hat die ja heute sich
möglicherweise laschet und sollte auch
eine art ja unfreiwilliges fernduell
geliefert haben
gut dann sind wir hier am ende nur mit
dieser sendung nicht mit den themen ich
bedanke mich bei heinrich oberreuter bei
urban priol weil ja ne bednarz und bei
peter zudeick liebe zuschauer morgen in
der phoenix runde schnelltests zinsen
grenzen dicht was hilft gegen die
mutationen jetzt war zunächst der tag
mit michael krons thema unter anderem
auch noch einmal der politische
aschermittwoch und im vorgriff auf die
morgige sendung jens spahn zum anteil
der gefährlichen virus mutanten an den
neuinfektionen hier in deutschland
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]
[Gelächter]